[Musique]
on les appelle les choux box les boîtes
à chaussures des petites maisons
ouvrières un seul étage construite sur
un bout de terrain sans fioritures ni
sous sol le strict minimum la maison
suivante c'est toujours en bois
fabriqués en gros madriers de bois pièce
sur pièce à la façon virale et
lambrissée de l'enveloppé de break à la
façon urbaine aux protégés contre feu
ajoutez un balcon en façade une corniche
en brique et quelques fleurs de lys et
le traditionnel castor à l'époque le
symbole des francophones des terrains
qui valent pas cher avec une maison
simple comme tout à construire avec un
petit budget ces maisons danse
s'épanouissent à travers le territoire
montréalais pour quelques sous les
ouvriers se rendant tramway de la maison
au boulot les choux box pause par
centaines autour des shops angus dans
rosemont mais également dans ahuntsic la
chine tétreaultville et ailleurs
la plupart des choux bucks ont été
modifiées au fil du temps meslier encore
quelques perles rares comme celle ci
c'est un style que je n'ai donc c'est
qu'un coup de coeur au niveau de
l'intérieur au niveau du look dans son
petit show box de buissons à pied car et
tout est resté intact depuis des années
le corridor central les murs en plâtre
brosser les boiseries les armoires
j'aime la solidité à le fait ses preuves
avec le temps donc je sais que la
structure elle et elle est bien j'aime
la grosseur elle est parfaite pour moi
j'aime aussi le terrain bien sûr en
avant pis la petite ruelle en arrière
même pour un spécialiste comme david
hanna c'est pratiquement une pièce de
collection
je dirais que je pense qu'on voit ici
est vraiment super de ce qu'on aura vu à
l'époque dans n'importe quelle box est
juste que ces éléments ont disparu
depuis donc le fait qu'on est passés ici
l éponge dans clac pour créer ce motif
est plongée d'as et c'est quelque chose
qui aurait disparu avec le temps
mais aujourd'hui beaucoup de ces mini
maisons sont en mauvais état sinon
carrément l'abandon et aucun règlement
municipal ne les protègent
spécifiquement on peut dire qu'ils ont
une valeur historique qui sont vraiment
des témoins de l'évolution de mode de
montréal madame gosselin rappelle que
les choux box bénéficie tout de même
d'une forme de protection puisque depuis
on ne peut plus raser un bâtiment ou le
modifier sans obtenir une autorisation
de l'arrondissement souvent des gens
veulent et s'agrandir les transformer
est ce qu'il faut faire c'est réfléchir
à comment accorder les transformations
tout en retenant la mémoire
architectural du chou bobst
à preuve ce joli show box auquel on a
ajouté un deuxième étage ses
propriétaires a dû négocier avec la
ville durant huit mois avant d'obtenir
un permis
notre but à nous d'agrandir c'était
vraiment trop grande sur la famille et
maintenant on en fit donc c'est vraiment
pour ça donc ce n'était pas dans l'idée
de revendre son condo séparer d'elle
flipper par fourneaux pour rester
montréal protéger le chou boxe et le
droit mais pas n'importe quel prix et
des choix qui sont en mauvais état
vraiment mauvais état et eu un moment
donné il va falloir qu'il détruit
explique comment ils vont faire pour les
empêcher de reconstruire un duplex ou un
triplex ils vont ils vont sûrement pas
les obliger à reconstruire un show box
d'un étage un siècle après leur
construction il reste encore pas mal de
chewbacca montréal et avec eux le
patrimoine ouvrier typiquement
montréalais mais pour combien de temps
se demande david hanna ces maisons ont
un rôle à jouer socialement
économiquement aujourd'hui en tant que
premier rachat de jeunes familles de
jeunes couples en ville semble que ça
mérite pas taxées la ville songe de plus
en plus explique christine gosselin il
est clairement temps qu'un vent de
protectionnisme se lève sur les choux
box qu'on puisse prendre un répit
identifié quatre catalogue et celles qui
ont une valeur patrimoniale qu'on
aimerait réservés
[Musique]
oh
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal
[Musique]